[Applaudissements]
c'était le 20 juillet 1969 l'homme
marchait sur la lune neil armstrong qui
plantait le drapeau américain
or au cours de ce voyage de quatre jours
et près de 400 mille kilomètres
l'astronaute transportait bien plus dans
ses bagages après sa mort en 2012
ces faits sont découvert un véritable
trésor
un drapeau emmener sur apollo 11
identique à celui planté sur la lune
estimée à 75 mille dollars
c'est le clou de la vente est une
combinaison des écussons une lettre du
président nixon des souvenirs que la
famille a préféré est dispersée plutôt
que d'ajouter aux collections des musées
une manière de souligner l'exploit we
understand
[Musique]
le milliardaire américain jeff bezos a
dévoilé aujourd'hui un projet d'al unis
soeur il veut créer une véritable route
vers l'espace
comme quoi l'exploit de neil amstrong
continue de faire rêver ici sébastien
desrosiers radio-canada morère